but in other news uh we're gonna be an
ax But Trash day's gonna have a big ass
yes
I'm involved yeah Joey uh is having a
family holiday right yeah uh I think we
talked about it before but yeah I'm
going to Vietnam so I unfortunately
won't be at ax this year but these two
will be and uh we're gonna be having a
massive trash taste booth at the
entertainment Hall yeah that should be
interesting because giving a booth today
actually is interesting as well I mean
the whole process was like yeah normally
just for like giant companies yeah I I
mean I saw uh We've so technically it's
already been announced that we're going
to be at ax but I don't think people
know currently that uh we're gonna have
an actual booth there and it's not like
Geeks plus it is like us that's a big
boy yeah it is a big Booth we are
competing against I believe hoyovus
you know they they have booths
it's a big [__] boys yeah
definitely the underdogs in that room
Ghibli bushy Road Hulu uh
[Music]
we're just chilling but uh yeah we kind
of decided to do something for ax
because we go every year and uh this
year we try to uh we decided to try
something a little bit different and uh
try to actually see what the booth
experience is like because we've seen a
lot of other people try to do booths
um and uh we kind of just wanted a
little bit of experience to what that
was like uh whether we're gonna do more
in the future kind of depends on how
well this one plays out because uh we
try to go as big as we could we didn't
like spare any expense
giant gacha machine yes yes which has a
lot of weird giant it's huge it's like
12 foot or bigger than that it's massive
yeah yeah
um so big that one of us can get inside
of it so if you go to the Hoya verse
Booth then you can go to albu for like
the real Gadget yeah
fans if if you if you need that gacha
fix just come to our booth yeah you can
watch some of the figures on the set I
think we were playing like we because
the gacha because we're the the main way
that we're funding this booth is by
selling limited uh ax merch which looks
[__] sick by the way yeah I don't
know if we can show it but I mean if we
can pictures maybe it looks so [__]
sick yeah especially if you buy some
merch you can spin the giant gacha
machine and yeah some of the prices go
up to uh like this [__] thing get
this bad boy yeah we're getting Goku as
well we're getting the Fate statue
it hurts to uh give the Fate statue away
but you can also win the face statue and
I feel like this is the gonna be the one
that people want the most uh we're gonna
have black Goku or Goku black you decide
it's black owner yeah it's just [__]
yeah
I'm just hyped because you know we
always get asked to be other people's
booths and I guess it was always kind of
like a it'd be like a fun little I don't
know see see what happens yeah yeah
because like you know like normally only
like giant corporations can do this uh
and we found out why because this is
ungodly expensive it's very expensive so
we were like let's so much so we
hopefully don't go back so if you're at
ax uh do us a favor do the boys a favor
and uh stop on over check it out uh
there's obviously a bunch of other stuff
as well we're gonna have uh claw
machines we've got a ton of claw
machines yeah again stuff you can only
get photo op stuff as well yeah we're
gonna have a replica of our set as well
yeah where you can sit uh with the voice
you can finally be a member of trash you
can be the fourth member of trash this
space is trash is fortnite overrated
yeah yeah let's find out yeah I think
we're just [__] hired I mean it's
been really cool going through the whole
process of yeah getting a space figuring
out how to build what in it and yeah how
much that costs yeah it's it's it's it's
it's it's been like it's been
eye-opening and I can see why normally
when you need to have a booth in ax uh
you are a big massive established
company uh because I don't think we're
gonna make a profit from this uh yeah if
I'm being honest
I don't know when occasionally yeah we
can't announce when me and Conor are
going to be at that Booth because one of
the big problems is uh we don't want to
cause a fire safety hazard because we
will be kicked out that makes you sound
so badass which is so popular I mean you
know like if people know you're coming
and lines are not good they don't like
lines so yeah we'll be there so just
make sure you tell us sometime we can't
tell you when we'll be there but we'll
be there I'll be there I'll be there in
spirit and Joey will get on a zoom call
with us I'll get on sometime yeah and
yeah we're gonna be filming a bunch of
stuff there as well so come check us out
at uh Anime Expo this year and we have
an actual booth
that's not the only thing we're doing at
ax well not the only thing you're doing
at ax drink what else am I doing at X
did you not want to talk about this oh
oh yeah I did sorry that's not LAX
though yeah that's yeah okay I was like
this has nothing to do with AI yeah I
should have said La yeah we're doing the
the charity auction which I think 100
hopefully should be announced by now and
if it isn't I'm very worried uh yeah on
June 29th we're doing uh well I'm uh
doing a charity event
um where I've just asked a bunch of
YouTubers to bring items to sell for
charity uh really excited for it because
this has been like months months months
months in production and yeah getting it
right and getting it perfect
um you know and the idea has changed a
lot over time initially I was just like
I'll just bring a bunch of my cosplays
and we'll auction them off in front of
like a real crowd uh and then it was
like well you know it kind of seems like
a waste to do all that just for that
because I can do that in my room let's
let's get more people involved and then
as I was getting more people involved I
was like I should just get everyone to
bring an item and we'll auction it off
or
yeah so
well yeah like you could be like so some
people because they don't have anything
like physical they can give away they're
just like oh like um you can have an
arrow with me teaching you something or
Oh okay that's cool uh you know because
then that way there's there's different
ways people can get value yeah
um you know and there's some some of
those that I think are I I don't wanna I
don't know what I will and won't
announce before because I kind of want
to get like I want to keep some things a
secret but some things are really cool
and I want people to know it's gonna
happen before
um but I you know and luckily pretty
much everyone I asked said yes so we've
got a ton of really big creators uh and
a ton of really cool items that I'm
super hyped to show off so some really
really expensive stuff and and some
absolutely dog [__] stuff which I think
will make it funny yeah uh and yeah
we're gonna have like a whole real crowd
and people can buy tickets that are very
very expensive
um but then the ticket will I can't
remember what exactly what it was
basically it'll be a donation to charity
right yeah um so very excited for that
is there anything you want to reveal
before or do you want to keep it all a
secret just trying to think what I
should reveal and what I shouldn't keep
seeing because right now I haven't said
anything
um well I mean it's happening in L.A yes
oh yeah it's happening it's happening in
LA but like you know the the tickets are
like there's only like 20 tickets right
so watch online uh it'll it'll be it'll
be fun uh should be able to watch it in
every time zone hopefully
um I'm excited for it we have like an
actual Auction House nice and we have
like a proper Auctioneer guy as well or
no I'm gonna be the older oh you're
going to be here
so I'm gonna be the host she's gonna be
auctioneering so I expect you to do like
the whole thing of like oh my God
I just might not understand what I'm
saying it's cool because they like
people can bid in person and at home
right so it'll be uh interesting to see
how quickly it might go off with people
bidding online yeah right uh versus in
person uh so very excited for it it
should be a fun Little Mix that I don't
think anyone's done before because it's
kind of weird and ambitious yeah and you
know I the whole thing came about
because I was like hey I just want to
Ludwig I was like I'd really like to do
this thing do you reckon you've got you
guys the off-brand would be interested
which is the company that he's a part of
right uh and yeah they were super down
for it and managed to find a good
production company in La so very hyped
for it should be like my most
well-produced stream of all time nice uh
let's hope that people turn up and watch
yeah so I'm sure I'm so hyped for it go
check it out we've uh also donated items
yeah gonna be there in person I'll be
there in person I'll be there in spirit
yeah
they're not like a lot of creators that
can't make it uh who are still
interested we'll still be there in some
way so don't worry
um but yeah I think it's uh it's gonna
be a lot of fun I'm super excited for it
yeah it's been a [__] ton of work uh
nice [__] yeah yeah every day I see kind
of messaging like different people being
like oh whatever yeah I've never
messaged many people for a project ever
because I just I always just felt kind
of weird asking people for stuff you
know you've done this before and I was
just like God this is so annoying having
to chase after everyone yeah it's like
hurting cats isn't it yeah well yeah I
mean it's like you know and I understand
because you're asking for someone to
give their time or something you know I
under I don't like asking people for
stuff a lot uh and so it was kind of
like I was like all right here we go
Gotta contact literally everyone I've
ever met yeah who is a significant
Creator to kind of get an item and get
them involved in some way
um but I'm really happy so far with the
with the people we we have on board so
really really interesting items as well
oh yeah nice good good and bad items
um excited I can't I couldn't imagine
trying to keep track of that many people
and uh sort out something physically
then getting the stuff again yeah turn
up is kind of a lot of work but I mean
it should be fun I'm bad enough okay I
guess change the topic now unless
there's something else you want to say
no no that's I mean just I'm just hyper
keep your eye out on keep your eye out
yeah I'll probably talk more about it
when maybe I don't know when we're
coming up to it or when I don't know
when it when it's done I have no idea
yeah just turn up come watch trainline
to June excited yeah um I'm bad enough
keeping up with uh messaging people who
like owe me money you know
I [__] despise it man the I I feel
like I'm the type of guy who if it's
just like a small amount of money I'm
just like [__] it whatever let's just
forget about it I don't think I don't
think anyone likes being the Repo Man
you know because being like Oh by the
way I'm here to take your [__] you know
like no one likes them that's that's
what I'm a guy who's just like if I can
pay a debt I I hate being in debt right
because I know I know the pain of the
person who is waiting not not even like
even if they're not waiting for money
you know the fact that they have to go
out their way to like message me to be
like you need to pay your money because
I know I know I'm gonna forget I know
I'm gonna [__] forget man yeah sure
yeah oh I'm also doing a panel with iron
Mass I forgot about that of some time at
ax so that'll be fun oh yeah we don't be
streamed as well we don't have our full
ax schedule right now I'm I'm sure I'm
gonna have some events
[Music]
well actually we'll actually update it
for once you know